basically any Observer that exists
inside the universe
is going to be computationally bounded
no any Observer like us I don't know I
can't say like us what do you mean what
do you mean like us well humans with
finite Minds you're including the tools
of science yeah yeah I mean and and as
we you know we have more precise and by
the way there are little sort of
microscopic violations of the second
order of thermodynamics that you can
start to have when you have more precise
measurements of where precisely
molecules are but for uh for a large
scale when you have enough molecules we
don't have you know we're not tracing
all those molecules and we just don't
have the computational resources to do
that and it wouldn't be uh you know I
think the the to imagine what an
observer who is not computationally
bounded would be like
it's an interesting thing because okay
so what does computational boundedness
mean among other things it means we
conclude that definite things happen we
go we take all this complexity of the
world and we make a decision we're going
to turn left or turn right and that is
kind of reducing all this kind of uh
detail into we're observing it we're
we're sort of crushing it down to this
this one thing yeah and and that if we
didn't do that
uh we wouldn't we wouldn't have all this
sort of symbolic structure that we build
up that lets us think things through
with our finite Minds we'd be instead
you know we'd be just we'd be sort of
one with the universe yeah so content
to not simplify yes if we didn't
simplify then we wouldn't be like us we
would be like the universe like the the
intrinsic universe but not having
experiences like the experiences we have
where we for example conclude that
definite things happen we you know we we
sort of have this this uh notion of
being able to make make sort of
narrative statements yeah I wonder if
it's just like you imagined as a thought
experiment what it's like to be a
computer I wonder if it's possible to
try to begin to imagine what it's like
to be in an unbounded computational
well okay so here's here's how that I
think plays out vibrations suck yeah so
I mean in this we talk about this
rouliad the space of all possible
computation yes and this idea of you
know being at a certain place in the
rouliad which corresponds to sort of a
certain way of of rep of a certain set
of computations that you're representing
things in terms of okay so as you expand
out in the rouliad as you kind of
Encompass more possible views of the
universe as you Encompass more possible
kinds of computations that you can do
eventually you might say that's a real
win you know we're colonizing the
rouliad we're we're building out more
paradigms about how to think about
things and eventually you might say we
we won all the way we managed to
colonize the whole Riyadh okay here's
the problem with that the problem is
that the notion of existence coherent
existence
requires some kind of specialization by
the time you are the whole rouliad by
the time you cover the whole rouliad in
no useful sense do you coherently exist
so in other words in inches the notion
of existence the notion of what we think
of as as definite existence requires
this kind of specialization requires
this kind of idea that we are we are not
all possible things we are the a
particular set of things and that's kind
of how we uh that that's kind of what
what makes us have a coherent existence
if we were spread throughout the rouliad
we would not there will be no coherence
to the way that we work we would work in
all possible ways and that wouldn't be
kind of a notion of identity we wouldn't
have this notion of kind of uh uh of of
coherent identity I am geographically
located somewhere exactly precisely in
the rouliad therefore I am as yeah the
cart kind of yeah yeah right well you're
in certain place in physical space
you're in a certain place in Royal space
and if if you uh if you are sufficiently
spread out you are no longer coherent
and you no longer have I mean in in the
in our perception of what it means to
exist and to have experience it doesn't
happen now so therefore so to to exist
means to be computationally bonded
I think so to exist in the way that we
think of ourselves as existing yes the
very active existence is like operating
in this place that's computationally
reducible so this is just giant mess of
things going on that you can't possibly
predict
but nevertheless because of your
limitations
you have an imperative of like what is
it an imperative or a skill set to
simplify or an ignorance a sufficient
level okay so the thing which is not
obvious is that you are taking a slice
of all this complexity just like we have
all of these molecules bouncing around
in the room but all we notice is you
know the the the the kind of the flow of
the air or the pressure of the air we're
just noticing these particular things
and the the big interesting thing is
that there are rules there are laws that
govern those big things we we observe
yeah so it's not obvious that's amazing
because it doesn't feel like it's the
slice yeah well right not a slice well
it's like uh
it's like an abstraction yes but I mean
the fact that the gas laws work that we
can describe pressure volume et cetera
et cetera et cetera we don't have to go
down to the level of talking about
individual molecules that is a
non-trivial fact and and here's the
thing that I sort of exciting thing as
far as I'm concerned the fact that there
are certain aspects of the universe so
you know we think space is made
ultimately these atoms of space and
these typographs and so on and we think
that uh but we nevertheless perceive the
universe at a large scale to be like
continuous space and so on
um we uh in quantum mechanics we think
that there are these many threads of
time these many threads of History yet
we kind of span so so you know in in
quantum mechanics in our models of
physics there are these time is not a
single thread time breaks into many
threads they Branch they merge and but
we we are part of that branching merging
Universe right and so our brains are
also branching and merging and so when
we perceive the universe we are
branching brains perceiving a branching
Universe yeah and so the fact that the
claim that we exp we believe that we are
persistent in time we have this single
thread of experience that's the
statement that somehow we managed to
aggregate together those separate
threads of time that are separated in in
the operation of in the fundamental
operation of the universe so just as in
space we're averaging over some big
region of space and we're looking at
many many of the aggregate effects of
many atoms of space so similarly in what
we call branchial space the space of
these these Quantum branches we are
effectively averaging over many
different branches of possible of
histories of the universe and so in in
thermodynamics we're averaging over many
configurations of you know many many
possible positions of molecules yeah so
what what we see here is so the question
is when you do that averaging for space
What are the aggregate laws of space
when you do that averaging over
branchial space What are the aggregate
laws of branchial space when you do that
averaging over the molecules and so on
what are the aggregate laws you get
and this is this is the thing that I I
think is just amazingly amazingly neat
that there are aggregate laws at all
well yes but the question is what are
those aggregate laws so the answer is
for space the aggregate laws the
Einstein's equations for Gravity for the
structural space time for branchial
space the aggregate laws of the laws of
quantum mechanics and for uh the case of
of molecules and things the aggregate
laws are basically the second law of
thermodynamics
and so the um though that's the and the
things that follow from the second world
of thermodynamics and so what that means
is that the three great theories of 20th
century physics which are basically
general relativity the theory of gravity
uh quantum mechanics and statistical
mechanics which is what kind of grows
out of the second row of thermodynamics
all three of the great theories of 20th
century physics are the result of this
interplay between computational
irreducibility and the computational
boundedness of observers and you know
for me this is really neat because it
means that all three of these laws are
derivable so we used to think that for
example Einstein's equations were just
sort of a wheel in feature of our
universe that they could be the universe
might be that way it might not be that
way quantum mechanics is just like well
it just happens to be that way and the
second law people kind of thought well
maybe it is derivable okay what turns
out to be the case is that all three of
the the fundamental principles of
physics are derivable but they're not
derivable just from mathematics they
require or just from some kind of
logical computation they require one
more thing they require that the
Observer that the thing that is sampling
the way the universe works is an
observer who has these characteristics
of computational boundedness of belief
and persistence and time and so that
that means that it is the nature of the
Observer
you know the rough nature of the
Observer not the details of how we got
two eyes and we've observed photons of
this frequency and so on uh but the the
the the kind of the very coarse features
of the Observer
um then imply these very precise facts
about physics and it's it's I think it's
amazing so if we just look at the actual
experience of the Observer that we
experience this reality it seems real to
us
and you're saying because of our bonded
nature it's actually all an illusion
it's a simplification yeah it's a
simplification right what's what's so
you don't think a simplification is an
illusion
no I mean it's it's well I don't know I
mean what's underneath
uh okay that's an interesting question
um what's real and that relates to the
whole question of why does the universe
exist and um you know what is the
difference between reality and a mere
representation of what's going on yes we
experience the representation yes but
the the question of so so one question
is uh you know why is there a thing
which we can experience that way
and the answer is
because this rouliad object which is
this entangled limit of all possible
computations there is no choice about it
it has to exist it has to there has to
be such a thing it is in in the same
sense that you know two plus two if you
define what two is and you put pluses
and so on two plus two has to equal four
yeah similarly this really had this
limitable possible computations just has
to be a thing you that is once you have
the idea of computation you inevitably
have the ruling yeah you're going to
have to have a rule yeah yeah right and
and what's important about it there's
just one of it it's it's it's just this
unique object and that unique object
necessarily exists and then the question
is what uh and then we
uh once once you know that we are sort
of embedded in that and taking samples
of it that it's sort of inevitable that
there is this thing that we can perceive
that is you know that our perception of
kind of physical reality
necessarily is that way given that we
are observers with the characteristics
we have
so in other words the fact that the fact
that the Universe exists is it's
actually it's almost like it's you know
to think about it almost theologically
so to speak and I I really it's it's
funny because a lot of the questions
about the existence of the universe and
so on they they transcend what kind of
the science of the last few hundred
years has really been concerned with the
science of the last few hundred years
hasn't thought it could talk about
questions like that yeah
um and uh but I think it's kind of and
so a lot of the kind of arguments of you
know does God exist you know is it
obvious that I think it in some sense in
some representation it's sort of more
more obvious that uh that something sort
of bigger than us exists than that we
exist and we are you know our existence
and as observers the way we are is sort
of a contingent thing about the universe
and it's more inevitable that the whole
the whole universe kind of the whole set
of all possibilities it exists but but
this question about you know is is it
real or is it an illusion you know all
we know is our experience
and so the fact that well our experience
is this absolutely microscopic piece of
sample of the rouliad and we're
um and and you know there's this this
point about you know we might sample
more and more of the rouliad we might
learn more and more about we might learn
you know like like different areas of
physics like Quantum Mechanics for
example the fact that it it was
discovered I think is closely related to
the fact that electronic amplifiers were
invented that allowed you to take a
small effect and amplify it up which
hadn't been possible before you know
microscopes have been invented that
magnify things and so on but they're you
know having a very small effect and
being able to magnify it was sort of a
new thing that allowed one to see a
different sort of aspect of the universe
and let one discover this kind of thing
so you know we can expect that in the
rouliad they're an infinite collection
of new things we can discover there's
there's in fact computational
irreducible it kind of guarantees that
there will be an infinite collection of
kind of you know pockets of reducibility
that can be discovered